all right so what we've got here I've
got the Schooley script that we're going
to write over here and then I've just
got the browser open we could obviously
start from scratch have it open up a
browser but here we go
and so what we're going to go ahead and
do is start here and the first thing we
want to do is we want to have the mouse
come to this address bar and like click
on the address bar so the way that we're
going to do that is we want to click and
where do we want it to click it's going
to be um right here so that's where we
want to click now just to make sure
because I in my think like the mouse I
believe where it makes that crossover is
where it will naturally go oh shoot oh
there we go again well naturally click
is there but if we go okay it's like all
my screens anyway
uh-huh so okay you can see where it
wants to click but you could tell it
like no I really want the mouse to click
here or here the next thing that you
might want to do that you can change is
sorry this probably looks really
confusing because it's showing like I've
got four monitors so it's like this huge
mess your should just be a regular
square though but what it's going to do
I wish there was a way for me to like
zoom into my main monitor anyway you can
see here there's got the similarity so
it's always a good idea to kind of check
this and see okay how many similar
places are there and you can require how
similar you want it to be like if we
drop this you can see that oh there's a
similar to here here here here here here
here
but obviously the most strong one is is
this one but if you raise it up enough
the only one it's going to find is the
correct one so anyway we just hit apply
okay and now you can see here in our
little image exactly where it's going to
stick the mouse to click on this image
so real quick since I know everyone's
just excited
heck Lisa Kelly let's hit run and see
what it does so we hit run oh we gotta
save it let's see I'll just run me so
you saw maybe hopefully with him um you
can see that it moved it took my mouse
and it moved it and we did click there
so now that's actually now that we've
clicked there next thing we might want
to do is we want to type in something so
let's say ty and in here we want to type
sent that Zeus sent Dexcom so now let's
let's actually save this so we don't run
into any problems let me save it locally
save and we're just going to save this
as a Saku e - awesome
so now what we'll do we'll run it and
let's see where it goes image I think
this must have been saving it somewhere
so let's let's retake this image real
quick I guess we'll have to yeah let's
just redo this image I think cuz it's
it's looking for it saves the images and
a little bit of a file basically and so
let's say where are we quick so since
those since we saved it in a new
directory I think that's that's the
problems it just doesn't know so let's
do that and then let's edit this target
offset we want to make let's just offset
just slightly why okay okay do not save
it let's run it and you can see okay now
it goes there it types sent Dexcom now
the next thing we want it to do is hit
the enter key
right and so you obviously can't say
that click and or something like that
right so now we need to change that up
so how do we do that so as far as I know
I believe you do he died and then like
we would do I think it's all caps enter
but you'll have to bear with me there's
also say you wanted to do like control
I see you can do like keydown oops we're
all cat like key down and do something
but for now we'll get to that eventually
so I think we can actually put syntax
calm and then you can say plus and then
do key you'll just go to uppercase at
key and then we'll do enter plus key
enter and that should take us to the
website we'll see what happens let me
empty out the address bar here let's
save our sakuni script and let's run it
goes here senators comm hits enter sure
enough it takes us to the website now
we're already logged into this website
so let me go ahead and log out real
quick let's log out hopefully it'll save
us logged out let's try it again let's
run it one more time see if it's keeps
us logged out Hey
oh yay uh so if you have something in
the address bar okay so here's a here's
a good thing to run through real quick
so what's happening is it's looking for
this image and this image contains a
completely empty bar so it's probably
having a hard time finding it like let
me click on this and see our matching
preview
yes as you can see it's not fine annex
we have a pretty stringent
match but I bet if we just turn it down
a little bit like here it would find it
pretty quick but there's a better way to
do it because you wouldn't want it to
find like multiple things because this
is where securely could go wrong
obviously you could use some good logic
with it
but what you can do is sense like for
example this will change like when
you're using a browser you know this
white might change your forward and
backs might change a little bit but for
the most part what's going to change the
most is going to be this the text and
the image recognition is that it's quite
good so you can use that to your
advantage but also it can kind of mess
you up sometimes so let me show you how
to fix this sort of a problem and then
I'll pause the video will continue on
and in the next video so let's say
instead let's get rid of this click and
the way what you can do to kind of
remedy this situation is take an image
so let's say okay we're going to click
here right or we're going to do a shoot
we shouldn't have sorry I hovered over
this button so that's going to cause a
problem so let me fix this really quick
so one more time click wait till it
comes up okay so we want to click in
this area make sure we don't getting
that blue but actually let's even do it
this way so we want to click in this
area but then what we do is we change
this target offset to actually be all
the way over here right so this is the
image it's going to look for and it's
going to click over here so that way
you're kind of circumventing any issues
with stuff being in there so let's hit
apply okay and now let's put this where
it needs to be first of all or cut and
paste this down here up here save and
now let's run it and hopefully that will
work out for us I kind of messed up our
URL let's try again warn thumb there we
go okay so now it's actually taking us
to send XCOM still the same way as
before and if something's in the address
bar let's try again
it might be because it's maybe not
highlighting me but I'll tell you what
you can do sometimes what you could do
is you could click and you can drag
over to here and then type the website
so I mean there's all kinds of different
things but Sequoia is not only for the
browser so and really if you're going to
be doing something in a browser it's
sometimes better to use selenium anyway
but I'm just trying to get you guys used
to using um Sakuni so anyway I'm going
to cut the video here and then we'll
continue on in the next video with
logging in with Sakuni so as always
thanks for watching stay tuned to the
next video and thank you for your
support your subscription